fais un tour du monde un peu particulier
dont nous allons vous parler maintenant
avec Didier renier bonjour Didier et
bonjour à nos invités bonjour alexandre
Poussin et à Sylvie Tesson qui sont
présents sur notre plateau aujourd'hui
un livre un livre qui bien sûr n'a plus
que plaire à Didier Régnier et qui nous
a plu également il s'agit d'un roulé sur
la terre ce livre le voici édité chez
Robert Laffont et qui retrace avec
beaucoup de détails les anecdotes cette
expérience de vie votre périple a duré
un an au total c'est ça
ah non combien de kilomètres pédaler
25000 km
c'est pas mal qu'est-ce qui fait Didier
avant de vous laisser parler messieurs
qu'est-ce qui fait de cette expérience
une expérience particulière j'ai
absolument tenu Olivier à te présenter
ces deux jeunes gens très bien qui ont
fait un tour du monde extraordinaire
parce que lorsque l'on parle d'aventure
on parle souvent de gros moyens de gros
sous de talkie-walkie d'hélicoptère de
balises Argos des moyens sophistiqués
souvent qui dénaturent en quelque sorte
l'aventure ça ce sont ces deux personnes
ce sont les auteurs d'une plusieurs
purement authentique puisqu'ils sont
simplement partis avec un vélo chacun
25000 km tu l'as dit pendant 365 jours
et avec et ça c'est assez intéressant à
noter seulement 6000 francs en poche
voilà pourquoi je tenais absolument à ce
que l'on parle aujourd'hui de cette
aventure parce qu'elle est authentique
avec un grand teint alors Alexandre et
Sylvain que commencer passé votre
rencontre est-ce que c'est dans le cadre
des études que vous vous étiez
rencontrés et puis surtout comment est
né cette idée complètement loufoque à la
veille du 21e siècle de se casser comme
ça pendant un an on se connaissait
depuis tout petit on a commencé à faire
les 400 coups qu'on avait 15 ans
grattant sur les histoires
on se connaissent un peu on a fait
l'alpinisme ensemble après on est parti
à 17 ans après le bac à travers les
plateaux d'Islande et puis on s'est dit
pourquoi pas aller plus loin et pourquoi
pas faire le tour du monde et puis à
vélo parce que c'est un moyen de
transport fabuleux et on voulait pas
partir en situation d'échec il a fallu
mener à bien d'abord un premier cycle
d'études pour pas être en rupture avec
nos parents en rupture avec la société
tous nous retenait ici finalement mais
on est parti moi après un diplôme de
sciences politiques Sylvain après un
diplôme de de géographie c'est un petit
peu des travaux pratiques qu'on a fait à
bicyclette autour du monde pour essayer
de voir confronter ce qu'on avait appris
sur les bancs de l'université voir la
réalité du monde par nos propres yeux un
peu une démarche de Candide vous savez
qui part comme ça plein de bons
sentiments autour du monde mais
finalement c'était quand même un petit
peu instruit avec un regard averti sur
le monde c'était c'était la façon pour
nous la bicyclette d'aborder le monde et
la réalité d'une façon la plus
authentique possible
voilà pas du tout une fuite non non ça a
été au contraire c'était une c'était
allé vers les gens et la bicyclette vous
permet de rentrer dans le quotidien des
gens et on a passé la plupart de nos
nuits invités chez les gens partageant
avec eux leur dîner partageant des des
scènes inoubliables en tout cas ça va
interpolle nous a confirmé vous n'étiez
pas rechercher par toutes les polices au
moment où vous avez quitté le territoire
est-ce que la volonté de ne partir
qu'avec 6000 francs c'était également le
fait de vouloir absolument vivre
intensément chaque étape de ce voyage
sans le grand luxe auquel enfin que l'on
peut s'offrir si on partait avec un
million de francs quand on arrive dans
un village avec des balles de jongles et
des flûtes on ne marche pas on ne va pas
à l'hôtel on ne va pas dans un
restaurant on est toujours accueilli par
les gens et deux tiers de nos nuits chez
l'habitant c'est c'est vraiment ce qui a
fait qu'on a dépensé que 6000 francs oui
c'était c'était une volonté c'était un
peu une contingence aussi parce qu'on
partait donc avec ces 1000 dollars qu'on
possédait mais comme Didier a dit on
n'avait pas de balises à gauche les
seuls balises Argos qu'on avait c'était
des flûtes et en guise de satellite on
avait des balles de jongles qui
tournaient autour de nos mains et de nos
vélos il faut que vous restiez sur le
service public et que vous vous êtes
intéressé auprès de Didier il y a donc
l'un de vos deux vélos il est encore
avec toute la poussière de l'expérience
vécu il est encore dans son jeu mais il
est plus contagieux non non on vous fait
confiance cela dit est-ce que vous
pouvez nous détailler les différents
éléments qui qui ont fait donc partie de
votre de votre voyage une visite des
lieux très rapide vous avez ici la la
sacoche du guidon qui est notre table de
chevet avec dedans les livres les balles
de gens et ça c'est le petit plastique
peut-être le petit classique la carte et
puis aussi des poèmes qu'on avait
photocopié qu'on apprenait au fur et à
mesure de du pédalage ici la cuisine
avec les casseroles la salle de bain
toute petite à qui on a pas fait
beaucoup de mal à droite avec le savon
de la brosse à dents le bidon d'eau là
c'est la réserve pour le désert combien
de litres 5 litres à l'avance un litre à
l'arrière qu'on était dans le Sahara ça
faisait 12 litres quand même trois jours
d'autonomie là vous avez la chambre à
coucher juste à côté de vous ici voilà
vous aviez trop de choses en fait on a
pris le démontre on a prévu à vivre
comme des assiettes et on revient avec
beaucoup moins qu'on que vous étiez
parti avec beaucoup plus on est revenu
sans sac de couchage par exemple tout
c'était vraiment une école de la 16
c'était le délestage permanent et
finalement à la fin on coupait tout en
deux on a vécu avec deux t-shirts deux
shorts de slip de paires de chaussettes
pendant un an et ça nous a suffi c'était
vraiment une école du dépouillement
voyons en images maintenant la première
partie de ce périple vous allez nous
aider à détailler tout ça des images qui
sont tournées par vous et qui a commencé
donc par l'Ouest vous êtes parti du côté
de l'Afrique donc Paris Espagne Maroc
la traversée de la drar mauritanien avec
la première épreuve la tôle ondulée
c'est difficile de conduire sur le sable
de sable on s'en fout on s'enlise mais
ça ne vous empêche pas de d'avoir des
moments de répit et de fun en effet là
c'était la route du Sahara Occidental
2500 km de goudron marocain alors
l'impéda les films et l'autre jour oui
pendant est-ce que commencer par
l'Afrique c'était penser réfléchi parce
que vous auriez très bien pu partir vers
l'est au départ ben c'est c'est en effet
mais c'était pour nous le moyen d'aller
vers le sud et de ne pas aller sur les
en hiver sur les plateaux anatoliens
turc et trois jours avant le départ on a
bifurqué vers le futur la petite
toilette du matin vous n'aviez pas
beaucoup de temps en fait vous pédaliez
à longueur de journée combien d'heures
par jour 8 heures par jour c'est ça qui
est important
c'était variable ça dépend des saisons
et des endroits là il faisait 40-45
degrés on planté la tente dans des
endroits un petit peu exiguës parfois
par sécurité par Fun aussi alors
deuxième grand moment de cette français
vous sautez par dessus l'océan et vous
atterrissez de l'Argentine
dans les Andes où il y a des pistes un
peu épouvantables dynamiques
et l'accueil à chaque fois triomphant
dans les villages avec ce moyen
extraordinaire de communication qui est
le vélo c'était comme ça chaque étape
dans chaque village ça c'est vraiment
universel tout autour du monde on a été
accueilli de cette façon là vous offre à
manger on vous réconfortait et c'est
comme ça c'est de ça qu'on a vécu ça
nous permettait de vivre sans argent
qu'on ne faisait que passer et on ne
restait jamais deux ou trois jours au
même endroit qu'on avait jamais de
problème mais c'est un petit peu en
gagnant le cœur des enfants qu'on
s'ouvrait la porte des parents et après
vous quittiez non ça se faisait en
nature jamais en argent là on arrive en
Thaïlande on a franchi le Pacifique en
faisant des sauts de puces à Tahiti à
l'île de Pâques en Nouvelle-Zélande
l'arrivée à Bangkok voici l'arrivée à
Bangkok en Thaïlande avec la pollution
des amitiés d'un jour
alors tout ça se fait en musique à
chaque fois des bras de fer des
jongleries ah oui c'est un champion de
boxe thaïlandaise et les inondations
classiques c'est le côté un petit peu de
l'Asie du Sud-Est de grosse surprise par
rapport à ce que vous pensiez pas le
tour du monde contre les idées reçues
c'est vrai qu'on avait on avait un
regard nuancé sur les choses un regard
du monde réel on a vu le monde réel
finalement pas celui des de la
télévision pardon pour vous de la des
radios et des champs comme ça et c'est
pas on n'a pas vu un monde
catastrophique on a vraiment vu un monde
chaleureux ou l'humanité est
omniprésente ça c'est la descente du
Mékong vers le Laos on l'a vécu avec des
trafiquants de drogue avec des gens qui
sont qui sont une réputation terrible
mais qui sont très accueillants et puis
avec une ancienne extraordinaire un jour
vous êtes dans une cabane beaucoup
d'enfants vous observent et que se
passe-t-il à ce moment-là Alexandre la
maison s'écroule alors ça je vous
raconte cette histoire est incroyable il
y avait 150 personnes qui ont surchargé
cette case sur pilotis on était là
manger du riz gluant silencieusement à
la main sous le regard de tous ces de
tous ces gens très silencieux d'un seul
coup on s'est retrouvé 70 cm en dessous
dans la poussière dans un fracas
incroyable la case venait de s'effondrer
et bien c'est dans un silence dans un
silence consécutif et d'un seul coup la
maîtresse de maison est partie d'un
éclat de rire tonitruant absolument
hilarant tout le monde a repris de plus
belle en cœur et c'est tout le monde
était mort de rire se rouler par terre
sa maison venait de s'écrouler c'était
plus beau jour de sa vie hein
imaginez une maîtresse de maison avec
son immeuble haussmannien qui s'écroule
et qui se met en milieu des décombres
avec la télé dans les trois quatre
porcelets la même façon ici alors vous
allez nous montrer justement vous avez
jongler et jouer du pipeau montrez-nous
là quelques secondes comment ça se
passait
quelle a été la clé en quelque sorte de
votre tour du monde on arrive dans le
village on a envie de se faire inviter
par vous par exemple on va vous joindre
et puis ensuite vous allez nous offrir
le JT le couvert parfait
pas mal pas mal du tout alors ça c'est
important Olivier à souligner parce
qu'on pense souvent qu'il faut de gros
moyens pour voyager et souvent même si
on ne parle pas plusieurs langues
lorsque l'on voyage avec un sourire et
des gestes tout à fait simple on s'ouvre
les portes du monde et c'est ce qu'ils
ont démontré pendant un an sauf les
portes de la Chine parce que là on a un
gros problème de communication
est-ce que vous avez eu des problèmes de
santé important ou pas Alexandre que
vous voyez là est un miraculeux un
miraculé mais même parce qu'il y a un an
et demi il dit tout jaune et il a
attrapé une hépatite et il a été soigné
grâce à une vieille grand-mère de
rencontrer dans le Balouchistan qui lui
a donné comme recette un peu ésotérique
et traditionnelle de manger un killion 1
kg de miel par jour donc moi je suis
allé lui chercher du miel dans tes rangs
j'ai fait tout tous les environs de
Téhéran pour trouver du miel et je lui
ai j'en ai trouvé j'ai des tas
d'adresses là au là pour trouver du miel
mille fleurs et Alexandre
[Musique]
avec les gendarmes de l'ambassade de
France et toute la journée voilà on va
essayer d'avaler mon pot de miel avec ça
à manger il faut avoir la foi pour pour
se guérir d'une hépatine incroyable en 3
semaines rémission totale de la maladie
le taux de transaminase a chuté
vertigineusement le médecin de
l'ambassade de France on a perdu sur
latin et j'étais guéri j'ai pu repartir
en France lui prescrivait un
rapatriement sanitaire d'urgence vers la
France mais malheureusement pour
Alexandre il était encore en
convalescence quand on est reparti et là
on a traversé les pays du RSS où on
pouvait pas passer une heure sans
rencontrer une bouteille de vodka tendu
qu'il fallait finir avec les douaniers
en perfusion depuis 6h du matin qui
était les hémisphères lessivés par la
vodka de partager
une histoire un peu incroyable c'est le
premier visa qui nous a été refusé
réellement retrouver la rationalité
occidentale ça il fallait aller à Moscou
acheter un visa on était 4000 km en
dessous donc on est rentré en Crimée
clandestinement dans le coffre d'un
commandant russe qui nous a fait passer
de l'autre côté dans salada avec les
vélos sur le toit on a roulé 7 jours
clandestinement jusqu'à Yalta on est
arrivé le jour où le Parlement de Crimée
faisait ses sessions la guerre donc des
chars partout dans les rues on se
réfugie dans le port on met les vélos
dans un petit bateau de 6 mètres 50 pour
rallier au dessin avec un petit marin là
on se fait prendre dans une tempête
catastrophique pour le bateau on se
réfugie la nuit dans un port qui n'était
pas prévu un quand on rentre dans le
port un bateau nous éprone on commence à
couler voie d'eau en colmat la brèche
enfin la panique et le lendemain matin
quand on se réveille on se rend compte
qu'on s'était réfugié dans une base
militaire ultra secrète de Crimée au
milieu des trois heures des avis zoo etc
alors quand les douaniers le lendemain
l'Obs s'est élevé ils en ont un petit
bateau de plaisance dans cette base
militaire et qui aborde de cyclistes
français avec les vélos démontés dans la
cale sans visa en clan des états et qui
pour convulsé ils ont ils ont cru qu'on
était des espions ils nous ont mis en
prison ils nous ont expulsé un modèle si
vous ne savez pas avec qui partir en
vacances et si vous êtes sachez que
Alexandre Sylvain sont libres cet été
pour vous faire vivre la grande aventure
la philosophie de ce tout le monde vous
en revenez dans avec quel état d'esprit
on en revient avec une vision une vision
du monde tout à fait particulière on a
on s'est aperçu que l'homme était
partout hospitalier et que tant qu'on
rencontrait des individus tout se
passait bien et que dès que les gens
commençaient à se grouper et a commencé
à évoluer au rythme des des grandes
pensées religieuses ou politiques alors
là commence à des problèmes mais l'homme
en tant qu'individu ouvre sa porte et
son cœur
[Musique]